répondez-moi il se trouve qu'à l'époque
mon père était donc ministre de la
jeunesse et des sports et dans le cadre
donc de sens de son action
il devait venir sur le campus de
nanterre où moi j'étais étudiante pour
inaugurer et la piscine de nanterre et à
l'époque donc il y avait comme une sorte
d'effervescence qui commençait sur le
campus c'était en janvier et les
événements laisse passer en mai et donc
à l'époque c'était pas plus d'une
quarantaine à peu près d'étudiants mais
qui commence est quand même à faire un
peu de grabuge et à leur tête il y avait
un homme un garçon dont qui s'appelait
daniel cohn bendit et lorsque mon père
est arrivé pour inaugurer la trentaine
d'étudiants l'attendait et à ce moment
là ils ont commencé à dire à mon père
qu'est ce que vous faites vous pour les
problèmes sexuels des jeunes étudiants
et mon père leur a répondu je viens
inaugurait des piscines et puis toi qui
m'a posé la question si tu as un
problème sexuel plonge donc la tête la
première tu verras ça résout déjà pas
mal de jeunes et puis à l'époque donc
comme mon père était ministre il était
suivi par fait tort de personnes dont un
préfet de police et le préfet de police
se trouvant que ce jeune homme s'était
mal adressée à mon père à demander comme
ils étaient de nationalité étrangère
qu'il soit expulsé et mon père a dit à
ce moment là non je suis désolé si on
doit expulser quelqu'un on excuse pour
le grison valable mais c'est tout de
même pas parce qu'il m'a posé cette
question là qu'il doit être expulsés du
territoire français
ce qui me paraît d'ailleurs très normal
est censé comme réponse et puis les
événements sont arrivés de 68 et là vous
savez les gens commençaient à perdre la
boule on savait plus très bien où on en
était surtout belle à des journaux
notamment un journal qui heureusement
n'existe plus aujourd'hui et qui étaient
orduriers et qui a commencé à dire
il semble que il paraît que on croit que
mais qui n'affirme mais jamais ce garçon
qui s'appelle cohn bendit n'a pas été
expulsé de france parce qu'il a été
protégé par le ministre parce que il
avait une affaire etc
or je n'ai jamais rencontré cohn bendit
qu'il a d'ailleurs écrit lui-même dans
un de ces dans un bouquin je crois et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui si je le vois
dans la rue eh bien moi je le
reconnaîtrai parce que je sais la tête
qu'il a je le vois des émissions de télé
à etc
mais lui et je crois incapable de dire
quelle est la couleur de mes yeux et je
finit d'ailleurs par lui regretter parce
que je me dis que tant qu'à faire qu'on
vous prête qu'une histoire autant
connaître vraiment la personne avec
laquelle justement voudrait bien on
rallume la lumière merci voilà la faire